an agent made a request to special agent
Miller to quote go into a a CHS
informant report that Miller just put
together an edit out that the agent was
present so hold on there a minute this
is a January 6th seditious conspiracy
case for the proud boys and there was a
special agent there was some kind of
federal agent present with these people
oh that's it that's evidence of federal
involvement right there
now here's the crazy thing the story
from Politico says this assistant U.S
attorney Jocelyn Ballentine who is
supervising the case for the justice
department acknowledged the likely spill
of classified information Thursday
morning she raised particular concerns
about a message sent to Miller by
another agent who works on Covert
activity
and who said she did not work on the
Proud boys case oh yeah I believe that
describing a supervisor's order to quote
destroy
338 items of evidence